The whole subject of Yom Tov Sheni when
you have somebody from Eretz Yisroel who comes
to the United States or somebody from America
who goes to Eretz Yisroel and the question
of what to do in both directions. It’s
a different question in both directions but there
are a number of important issues that we
need to think about. Number one, when I
go to the opposite, I don’t know what
you call it, the opposite gender, when I
go to the opposite location am I supposed
to behave the way they do or am
I supposed to do what I originally was
supposed to do from my origin, from the
location where I actually live? That’s question number
one we have to talk about. Question number
two is let’s say I’m an Eretz Yisroel
and I’m keeping two days of Yom Tov
which we’re going to have to discuss in
a moment, if that’s what I’m doing, would
I be allowed to go to someone who
is an Israeli, a legitimate Israeli and say
to them, look, I’m keeping Yom Tov today,
for me it’s Yom Tov Sheni, would you
be able to turn the lights on for
me? Am I allowed to instruct somebody who
is not observing Yom Tov to do the
Melacha for me? Question number three, let’s say
I go to Eretz Yisroel and I am
of the opinion that I should only keep
one day of Yom Tov, there are legitimate
opinions who say that, there are many people
who do that, big Machlokes as we’ll see
in a few minutes, let’s say that is
what I’m doing, would I be allowed to
fly home back to America on Yom Tov
Sheni? I don’t want to miss another day
of work, I don’t want to have to
wait until after Yom Tov is over and
then fly back after Yom Tov and miss
a whole day or potentially two days because
maybe it’s Shabbos right after, whatever it’s going
to be, it will certainly make my life
easier if I fly home on Yom Tov
Sheni. Would I be allowed to do that
and if so is there a way that
I’m supposed to do that? Those are the
questions that I would like to discuss. We
don’t have that much time so maybe you’ll
hold off on your question and we’ll get
it later. We begin with a Mishna in
Masechet Psachim on Daf Nun where the Mishna
goes through a whole list of different Minhagim
that certain communities have and other communities do
not have. And the Mishna says, well what
happens when you have a clash? What happens
when I have a community where I grew
up that has this Minhag and now I
get married or I move locations and I’m
now finding myself in a new place which
has very different Minhagim? So what do I
do then? The Gemara says I should always
do Ke-minhag Ha-makom, I should always do like
the Minhag of the location where I live
V'al yeshane adam mipnei ha-machlokes, I should not
do differently than other people in the neighborhood
because it will cause dispute, it will cause
distance between myself and the rest of the
community and therefore the Gemara advises that we
should always make sure to follow the Minhag
Ha-makom. Now, how far does that go? It’s
a good question. Let’s say I move to
a community where everybody’s from German descent and
they only wait three hours but my family
waits six hours, that’s not called being Meshane
miminhag hamakom, that is my personal custom that
happens in my house, no one’s going to
be uncomfortable about the fact that I’m doing
that. Or if I have a Chumra on
Shabbos that I choose not to use the
Eiruv, that’s not called being Meshane mipnei ha-machlokes,
everybody uses the Eiruv, I have a right
to be Machmir. What the Gemara here is
talking about is let’s say if you have
whatever, it doesn’t matter, but the Gemara basically
says the rule is whenever I have a
certain custom in a community, I should follow
that custom. For example, writes the Gemara, let’s
say I’m in a community where they’re keeping
two days of Yom Tov and I happen
to come from a place where they only
keep one day of Yom Tov, so for
example I’m from Eretz Yisroel and now I
come to the United States where they all
keep two days of Yom Tov and for
whatever reason I happen to be here instead
of being at home in Eretz Yisroel, says
the Gemara, I have to make sure that
I don’t do anything on the second day
of Yom Tov because I’m in a community
where no one’s doing anything on the second
day of Yom Tov. What’s it going to
look like when nobody’s driving, nobody’s handling their
phones, nobody’s on their computer, and I’m walking
up and down the streets driving my car
with my phone out, I have my computer,
I have my iPad, what would that look
like? Says the Gemara, that would be very
uncomfortable and therefore you would not be allowed
to do it. With one caveat, if you’re
from Eretz Yisroel and now you happen to
be in Chutz L'aretz, if you are Betoch
Ha-yishuv, if you’re within the confines of the
Jewish community then you are restricted, you are
limited to do what the Jewish community does.
However, if you are Ba-midbar, let’s say I
come to the United States and I happen
to be in a hospital, I have a
family member in a hospital somewhere and there
is no Jewish community anywhere around me and
I’m really a Ben Eretz Yisroel and for
Yom Tov I’m not going to be anywhere
within the Tchum of a Jewish community, in
that case says the Gemara I’m allowed to
observe one day of Yom Tov. Why? Because
I’m not being Meshane miminhag hamakom, there is
no Makom, there is no Minhag here, I’m
not part of the community, I’m not together
with anybody else and therefore there would be
no problem for me to do Melacha in
that circumstance. Writes the Shulchan Aruch, this is
paskened in Shulchan Aruch Bnei Eretz Yisroel shebau
l'chutz l'aretz, if you have Jews from Eretz
Yisroel who normally only keep one day of
Yom Tov and now they come to Chutz
L'aretz where we keep two days, says the
Gemara, they are not allowed to do Melacha
on Yom Tov Sheni if they find themselves
within the confines of the Jewish community on
Yom Tov Sheni. However, what the Shulchan Aruch
here does not say is what kind of
Melacha are they not allowed to do. Shulchan
Aruch just says they can’t do Melacha. What
about Melacha b'tzina? Which means once nobody else
is around and I'm in the privacy of
my own home. So it's true I'm in
a Jewish community here in chutz l'aretz but
I'm in my own room. Nobody's looking into
the windows of my room. Would I be
allowed to use my phone or my computer
in my room or would you say no?
Once I'm in chutz l'aretz I have to
observe Yom Tov Sheni like everybody else and
I'm not allowed to distinguish myself from them
even if it is b'tzina, even if it's
in the privacy of my own home where
nobody else is going to be. That is
a major dispute among the Rishonim. Tosafot famously
writes in Masechet Pesachim that even devarim sheb'tzina
would not be permissible because once you come
to a place where they keep two days
of Yom Tov, you have to observe two
days of Yom Tov just like them and
you would not be allowed to do melacha.
There are a number of great Rishonim who
disagree. Great Rishonim means the Ran, the Rosh,
the Rambam. Those are major major Rishonim who
disagree. And very surprisingly even though the Rambam
and the Rosh and the Ran all disagree
with the Ba'alei haTosafot, the Shulchan Aruch I'm
sorry the Mishnah Berurah and the Magen Avraham,
all the classical poskim give their unequivocal opinion
which is that you are not allowed to
do melacha even b'tzina when you are in
chutz l'aretz even if you're a Ben Eretz
Yisrael, even if you're behind closed doors, even
if you think nobody's watching, it would not
be something that would be permissible. Rav Moshe
Feinstein has a tshuvah: are you allowed to
take a shower, a hot shower on Yom
Tov Sheni if you are a Ben Eretz
Yisrael who happens to be in America? So
Rav Moshe says probably in terms of the
shower it would be permissible. Why? Because there
are permissible ways for somebody who's observing Yom
Tov to take a shower himself. So nobody
automatically knows that you're doing anything wrong. When
you go in the shower maybe you're doing
it the right way. Maybe you're taking a
cold shower. Maybe you're doing what the Gemara
says eiver eiver which means you're only bathing
one part of your body at a time,
which is permissible on Yom Tov. So the
Gemara I'm sorry Rav Moshe Feinstein says there
are certain things that you may be allowed
to do but in general he says this
would be something that we should certainly be
careful about. The Mishnah Berurah as I said
is machmir and he says like the Ba'alei
haTosafot that when the Shulchan Aruch says you're
not allowed to do melacha in chutz l'aretz
it means even b'tzina, even in the privacy
of your own home it would not be
permissible. Now I found a very interesting comment
last night actually of Rav Nevenzahl in his
comments on the Mishnah Berurah where he says
yes maybe that was back then when it
was so unusual for people to travel to
different communities and if you were going to
do something different than everyone else people would
say wow why is this person acting differently?
Why is he sticking out? Why isn't he
following the protocol? But now says Rav Nevenzahl
everybody knows there are always people flying back
and forth from America to Eretz Yisrael and
vice versa and it wouldn't even make you
feel uncomfortable if you saw somebody doing melacha
here on Yom Tov Sheni. What would you
say? Your conclusion would be not that this
person is not a religious person but rather
this person must be from Israel even if
I don't know them. Right? You see somebody
walking down the street with a yarmulke and
tzitzit on Yom Tov Sheni on their phone
you would understand either the person is a
doctor and therefore it's pikuach nefesh or you
would say the person is from Eretz Yisrael
and they're visiting here. And nobody says Rav
Nevenzahl he thinks that it's a very different
ballgame today when we deal with the situation
that we're in where people are traveling all
the time. He suggests that maybe this would
not be a problem. Again that's a tremendous
chiddush. I don't know if that is accepted.
My father definitely does not agree with that.
He says we should follow the psak of
the Mishnah Berurah which is that even today
when we have people traveling back and forth
we have to be careful if you find
yourself a Ben Eretz Yisrael who finds themselves
in chutz l'aretz is not allowed to do
melacha on Yom Tov Sheni here even b'tzina.
And my father likes to tell the story
that there was once an individual who came,
he was a big talmid chacham from Eretz
Yisrael who came to America and he had
an apartment in the same building as my
parents. And there was somebody two years after
this talmid chacham went back to Israel, there
was somebody in the building who came to
my father and said remember that rabbi who
was here? How come he wasn't careful about
Shabbos? Like what's the deal with him? So
my father said what do you mean? Of
course he was. He was a big talmid
chacham. He said no I saw the lights
were always going on and off in his
house on Shabbos. And my father said how
can it be? There's no way. So my
father said maybe it was Yom Tov Sheni
and you saw the lights going on and
off not on Shabbos or Yom Tov, you
saw them on Yom Tov Sheni and he
doesn't observe Yom Tov Sheni. So my father
said even when you're in the privacy of
your own home and you think nobody's watching
but the lights are going on and off
you have to be careful. You never know
who on the other side of the building
is going to notice the melacha that you're
doing. So I asked my father yesterday what
about using my phone? Using my phone nobody's
going to know right if I'm in my
room. It's not like the phone is going
to light up the whole room. No one's
going to see. I'm under the blankets. Nobody
sees. So my father had a chiddush where
he said using the phone he still thinks
is a problem. I was tremendously amazed that
he knew that if somebody looks on, he
thought it was text messaging but it's WhatsApp,
they can see when the last time you
were on. It was like what I know
but I was like daddy wow that's very
impressive that he knew that. So my father
said people are going to look at your
phone later and they'll see you were doing.
So he said he thinks that we should
not be doing any melacha on Yom Tov
Sheni even if it means being on your
phone. the phone in the privacy of your
own home, it's still not something that should
be done. Now, what about going in the
opposite direction, which is relevant for many of
us here? Sometimes we as Bnei Chutz La'aretz
travel to Eretz Yisrael for Yom Tov and
the question then becomes, what do we do?
That is a very famous dispute among the
Gedolei Acharonim, what exactly are we supposed to
do? Now, why is it a dispute among
the Acharonim? Why is it not a dispute
in the Rishonim? You know why? It wasn't
a possibility. If you lived in Spain in
the days of the Rishonim, there was no
way you were going back and forth from
Eretz Yisrael to Chutz La'aretz. It was like
a once-in-a-lifetime. Either you lived in Chutz La'aretz
or you moved to Eretz Yisrael like the
Ramban and you stayed in Eretz Yisrael. Once
you moved to Eretz Yisrael you're a Toshav
Eretz Yisrael and you keep one day of
Yom Tov. Now, Rabbi Yosef Karo said that
there were people who used to be Olei
Regel in his generation, in the 1500s. Jews
who lived outside of Eretz Yisrael used to
come for Yom Tov and what did they
do? So the Beit Yosef writes in his
Sefer Avkat Rochel, which is a very unpopular
Sefer of the Beit Yosef that nobody learns,
but in there he writes that the practice
was when people came to Eretz Yisrael for
Yom Tov they used to observe two days
of Yom Tov. That is what he writes
in the 1500s. About 200 years later, the
Chida was one of the great Gedolim in
Eretz Yisrael, and the Chida writes in the
1700s that he had seen the same practice.
He had seen that people who came to
visit Eretz Yisrael for Yom Tov used to
keep two days of Yom Tov. About 100
years after him along came the Pe'at HaShulchan
who was one of the Talmidim of the
Vilna Gaon who moved to Eretz Yisrael, his
name was Rav Yisrael Mishklov, and he writes
in his Sefer that people are supposed to
keep two days of Yom Tov when they
come to Eretz Yisrael because after all you
are only visiting, you're a Ben Chutz La'aretz,
you happen to come for Yom Tov, that
doesn't change your status, and therefore we're going
to keep things as they are and you're
going to stick to the way you're supposed
to observe Yom Tov. That is the opinion
of three of the great Poskim: number one,
the Beit Yosef; number two, the Chida; and
number three, the Pe'at HaShulchan. It is, however,
very well known that there is a different
opinion and that is of the Chacham Tzvi.
The Chacham Tzvi lived in the 1600s and
the Chacham Tzvi writes that he believes if
you come to Eretz Yisrael you have to
observe one day of Yom Tov like the
Jews in Eretz Yisrael. If you're going to
observe two days, he says, that would be
Bal Tosif. You're not allowed to add on.
Right now you find yourself in a location
where everybody's keeping one day. If everyone's keeping
one day, you also have to keep one
day. There is a somewhat unusual opinion of
Rav Ovadia Yosef. He has a long Tshuva
about this in the Yechaveh Da'at where he
writes there's a difference between somebody who's single
and somebody who's married. If you're married and
you have a house in America and then
you happen to go to Eretz Yisrael for
Yom Tov, there's no chance in the world—I
mean, there's a remote, remote possibility—but there's no
chance in the world for most regular people
who are traveling for Yom Tov that you're
actually going to stay in Eretz Yisrael. But
let's say you're single and you go to
Eretz Yisrael for Succos or for Pesach and
then you meet a nice boy there. So,
worst comes to worst, if you like the
boy enough and he says, you know, I
insist that we're going to live in Eretz
Yisrael, we're not leaving. If you love him
enough you're going to stay. Says Rav Ovadia,
therefore if you're single maybe it's different than
if you're married. That's a very unusual, interesting
opinion. If you happen to be a Sefardi
you should be aware of that, but that
is not generally the accepted opinion. So here
we have a basic two opinions which say
on the one hand you should keep two
days like the Beit Yosef says because you
are a Ben Chutz La'aretz; on the other
hand you have the Chacham Tzvi who says
it would make more sense to observe one
day like the people in Eretz Yisrael. The
popular opinion for all the years has always
been that you observe two days of Yom
Tov. If you're visiting Eretz Yisrael, you are
considered a Ben Chutz La'aretz and you observe
two days of Yom Tov. Of course, the
other opinion is legitimate. The Chacham Tzvi was
one of the major Poskim, he's not a
lightweight. He's a real opinion in the Poskim,
but that was generally not the accepted opinion.
The Mishnah Berurah himself says unequivocally you have
to observe two days of Yom Tov if
you are visiting Eretz Yisrael and there's no
two ways about it, that's what he says.
In recent years for some reason the tide
seems to have shifted in the other direction
and many people follow the Chacham Tzvi. I'm
not exactly sure why but many people do,
against the advice of the Mishnah Berurah and
many of the other great Poskim, but whatever,
as I said, both of these are very
legitimate opinions. My father happens to have a
different opinion which is we should be Machmir
in both directions. So he feels you should
keep two and a half days of Yom
Tov. What does that mean? Not just two
days, you should keep extra. So how do
you keep two and a half days of
Yom Tov? It means you should follow the
opinion of the Beit Yosef which says that
you're a Ben Chutz La'aretz and therefore you're
obligated to keep two days of Yom Tov,
but you should also be Choshesh for the
opinion of the Chacham Tzvi, which means you
should listen to someone else make Havdalah after
the first night of Yom Tov in order
that just in case it's not Yom Tov
you cover that, and you should put on
Tefillin on the second day of Yom Tov
just in case it's not Yom Tov anymore.
So this way you cover all the different
opinions and you don't make any mistakes. That's
what he feels and that's what he does
when he goes to Eretz Yisrael. But again,
this is a very important issue and anyone
who has this question needs to ask somebody
who they trust to get guidance on what
it is that they should do. The question
then becomes let's say I'm in Eretz Yisrael
and I'm following the Psak of the In
the Mishnah Berurah *Mishnah Berurah*, which follows the
psak *psak* of *Rabbi Yosef Karo* and the
*Chida* and the *Aruch HaShulchan* that you keep
two days of Yom Tov. *Yom Tov*, what
do we do about *davening*? What do we
do about having *minyanim*? So I'm going to
observe Yom Tov? *Yom Tov*, which means I
should *daven* Yom Tov *Yom Tov tefillah*, because
for me it's Yom Tov? *Yom Tov*, it's
not weekday. So am I supposed to have
big American *minyan* in the middle of Yerushalayim
*Yerushalayim* when Yerushalayim *Yerushalayim* proper is not observing
Yom Tov, *Yom Tov* anymore? Now I'm going
to come with my whole group that's here
staying in the Inbal and we're going to
have our own *minyan*. It seems very strange.
So the *Mishnah Berurah* says that he feels
you should *daven* the Yom Tov, *Yom Tov
tefillah* betzina. *b'tzina* in your own house. That's
what the *Mishnah Berurah* says and he says
that's called *meshaneh bifnei hamachlokes*. Every other *shul*
that you go to in *Rechavia*, in *Talpiot*,
in Yerushalayim *Yerushalayim* all over the place, everywhere
you go, they're going to be *davening* weekday
*Shemoneh Esrei*. All of a sudden we come
to your *shul*, you have everybody's wearing Yom
Tov *Yom Tov* clothing, everybody is *davening* a
different *nusach hatefillah*, everyone's *davening* a Yom Tov
*Yom Tov tefillah* and you happen to be
*laining* on a day when we're not supposed
to be *laining*. It seems very strange and
therefore the *Mishnah Berurah* says that would be
differentiating yourself from the rest of Yerushalayim. *Yerushalayim*
which would certainly not be appropriate. That's what
he says. However, the Beis Yosef *Beis Yosef*
writes that in his generation, that is not
what everybody followed. In his generation, in the
1500s, even those who came to Eretz Yisrael
*Eretz Yisrael* to visit for Yom Tov *Yom
Tov* used to make public *minyanim* and he
says that doesn't cause a *machlokes*. If you
live in Eretz Yisrael *Eretz Yisrael*, good for
you, go to your regular *shul*, your regular
*shtiebel* that you *daven* in and that's fine.
Nobody asked you to come to the Inbal.
If you come to the Inbal and you
see they're in the middle of *laining*, you're
going to say to yourself oh this must
be the Americans who came to visit. This
is not going to make a *machlokes*. What
does the Gemara *Gemara* mean when it says
you should always follow the *minhag hamakom*? That
means if by not following *minhag hamakom* you're
going to cause a rift in the community,
but this is not causing a rift. You're
*davening*. Everyone should *daven* wherever they *daven* and
that's fine. And therefore the *Beis Yosef* is
of the opinion that there's no problem. What
becomes very unclear and somewhat complicated to define
is when is someone going to be defined
or classified categorized as a Ben Eretz Yisrael
*Ben Eretz Yisrael* and when are they classified
as a Ben Chutz La'aretz *Ben Chutz La'aretz*?
It's not always so simple. It's not always
so simple. We just gave an example of
somebody who lives in Eretz Yisrael *Eretz Yisrael*
or somebody who lives in Chutz La'aretz *Chutz
La'aretz* and goes to visit once in a
while for Yom Tov *Yom Tov*. But now
we have a much more complicated system where
you have people who live in Chutz La'aretz
*Chutz La'aretz* but who own apartments in Israel
or who own businesses in Israel and fly
back and forth all the time. So how
do you classify them? How do you categorize
them? That's what's become much more complicated today
than it ever was. It used to be
somebody went to visit Eretz Yisrael *Eretz Yisrael*
once in a blue moon, it was like
an unusual shaylah *shaila*, but here where we
have people going back and forth who own
property in both places, who own businesses in
both places, that is a big question. So
to that we have to actually analyze a
little bit further. We have a *tshuva* of
the *Maharit Tzahalon*. That was someone by the
name of Yom Tov *Rabbi Yom Tov Tzahalon*.
You've probably never heard of him. He was
a *talmid* of the *Alshich*. The *Alshich* was
a contemporary of the *Beis Yosef*. So this
was in the 1500s. The *Maharit Tzahalon* got
a very strange *shaila*. Here was a *shaila*.
Nobody should learn from this *shaila* because it's
not relevant to us, but the *shaila* was
there was a man who was married to
two different wives, which in itself is a
problem. How do you keep up with two
wives? Most people can't keep up making one
wife happy, right? So he was married to
two wives. To make things even more complicated,
one wife lived in Eretz Yisrael *Eretz Yisrael*
and the other wife lived in Chutz La'aretz,
*Chutz La'aretz*. So how are you going to
work that out? No problem, he had a
system. Here's the system. One year he's with
this wife, and the next year he's in
*Chutz La'aretz* with the other wife. That's the
arrangement that he had. And somehow everybody was
happy. I don't know. Or not. Doesn't say
whether they had *shalom bayis* or maybe he
was a horrible husband and that was a
good *shalom bayis* for him to be away
for a year. I don't know. But the
*Maharitatz*, the *Maharit Tzahalon* writes this question and
he wonders what does this man do about
Yom Tov *Yom Tov*? Right, one year he's
going to spend the *Yomim Tovim* in Eretz
Yisrael, *Eretz Yisrael*, *Pesach*, *Shavuos*, *Succos*, next year
he's going to spend *Pesach*, *Shavuos*, *Succos* in
*Chutz La'aretz* because he's going to be with
his other wife and he keeps flipping back
and forth. So what does he do? Isn't
that an interesting *shaila*? It's fascinating. Amazing. So
the *Maharit Tzahalon* writes that the answer is
we cannot really know who you are because
you really have two different places that you
call home and that you legitimately call home.
I have a wife here with children here,
and I have a wife over there with
children there. So you can't say this is
more my house than that one and therefore
he comes to the conclusion you have two
houses and therefore when you're in Eretz Yisrael
*Eretz Yisrael* you keep one day of *Yom
Tov*, on the years that you're in *Chutz
La'aretz* you keep two days of *Yom Tov*.
That's what he writes. Which means he introduces
us to the possibility of a person who
can actually have two locations. I can be
a Ben Chutz La'aretz. *Ben Chutz La'aretz* when
I'm in *Chutz La'aretz*, I can be considered
a Ben Eretz Yisrael. *Ben Eretz Yisrael* when
I'm in Eretz Yisrael *Eretz Yisrael*. Fascinating. And
he introduces us to this concept of somebody's
status that changes depending on where they happen
to be. There is a discussion, the Imrei
Emes the Imrei Emes was one of the
Gerer Rebbes. He was thinking about coming to
Eretz Yisrael, for a few months a year
and he sent a to the Gedolim in
Yerushalayim to ask them what he was supposed
to do when he came to Eretz Yisrael,
and it overlapped, it coincided with a How
should he observe Should he be like a
ben Eretz Yisrael. even though he plans to
go back for the other half of the
year? Let's say he was on semi-retirement, I
don't know exactly what the arrangement was, but
he was going to be there for a
little bit and then he was going to
leave. So what was he supposed to do?
So that was the question that the Imrei
Emes, sent to the Gedolim of Yerushalayim and
the conclusion that they wrote to him was:
If you live in for six months at
a time, then you can consider yourself a
ben Eretz... not If you live in Eretz
Yisrael, for six months at a time, then
you're considered to be a Ben Eretz Yisrael
If you're there for less than six months,
then you're a Ben Chutz La'aretz and you're
only considered to be visiting. How did they
come up with that strange idea? What is
six months? Why should that be the case?
So you say, oh six months is a
half year, but so what? Why should six
months determine? So here's where it comes from.
The Rama in Yoreh Deah has a very
interesting comment. We have all kinds of people
in our communities, and there are some people
who like to take nedarim. I promise I'm
going to do that, I promise I'm not
going to do this, I will do this,
I won't do that. Now some people take
upon themselves not just all kinds of promises,
but all kinds of strange promises. So the
Gemara, says somebody gets very angry at something
that happens in the community and they say,
I promise that I will never get benefit
from anyone in this city. You're all evil,
everyone's terrible, I will never get benefit from
anyone in the city. So what does that
mean? Means the next week when somebody drops
off flowers for Shabbos to his house, he's
not allowed to accept it. And when somebody
comes after his wife has a baby and
gives them a gift card, you're not allowed
to take it, why? Because everyone in the
city is evil and you said I promise
I'm never going to get benefit. What happens
if you have someone who just moved into
town from Memphis, right? Moves to New York.
So the Memphis person is obviously not as
evil as the person from New York. Of
course not. So what do you do for
all those listening online, I'm just giving live
examples from the people in the room, don't
worry, kulam tzaddikim, everyone's wonderful. So the question
is, if somebody moves from Memphis to New
York, at what point do we say you're
part of the evil New York people that
I've made a neder I'm never going to
get hana'ah from them? When's where's the cutoff?
Says the if you're there for six months,
then we say you're already a New Yorker.
If you're here for less than six months,
then we say no, you're really from Memphis
and you just happen to be here for
a little bit, you're visiting, but that really
is not what determines your status as being
a ben ir in terms of getting hana'ah
from a person who you made a neder
not to get hana'ah from. From there the
Gedolim of said, you see that if you're
in a place for six months you then
become a member of that community. Right? That's
what it says there. So that maybe we
can transfer that logic to this question as
well. The the Gerer Rebbe when he wanted
to move semi-retirement to and he had the
question what's he supposed to do, so how
do we determine? Let's figure out. Are you
going to be here for six months? Then
we could say you're considered a ben ir.
If you're not here for six months, then
we say you're considered a That's the conclusion
that they wanted to come to. Rav Asher
Weiss has told me that he finds that
to be very difficult. The whole reason why
there we determine it based on six months
is because binedarim haloch achar lashon bnei adam.
When we talk about a neder we try
to figure out what did the person mean
when they made this promise, when they made
this vow? What did you have in mind?
That's what matters. That's what determines the purview
of your promise. So what the Shulchan Aruch
is describing there is, what do most people
think when I say \"all the people in
my city are x or y\"? They mean
all the permanent residents of my city are
x or y. And if somebody's here for
six months, I meant to include that person.
If somebody's here for less, I didn't mean.
But you can't bring a proof from the
story by nedarim and you can't transplant that
logic to a different story here by Yom
Tov Sheini and whether Eretz Yisrael, is going
to be your dwelling place with regard to
Yom Tov Sheini, that's not relevant to our
case, perhaps that's a very different logic. So
I find Rav Asher Weiss approach to be
extremely reasonable. And he says the truth is
you really need to think about a number
of different factors that come to play in
determining where someone's residence really is. And what's
the litmus test? He said there are a
few things that you need to take into
account. Number one, if when you go to
Eretz Yisrael you stay in a hotel and
you don't have your own house or you
don't have your own apartment, it doesn't mean
you own it, but meaning if I have
an apartment that's on a long-term lease, doesn't
have to belong to me, but this is
my home. If you don't have that, either
a home that you own or a home
that's designated for you that you go to
all the time, that you're renting or that
you bought, then you can't consider yourself to
be a Ben Eretz Yisrael That's that's off
the table. That's number one. Number two he
says, if let's say if let's say I
have young children who are still of school...
age which requires me, not college age, but
grade school, which requires me to be in
America. It doesn't matter how many times a
year you come to Eretz Yisrael the fact
that your children are still enlisted in a
school in America, that means you are an
American. You can't just pick up and go
to because you're bound by your children to
the school. And even if I go for
Shalosh Regalim he argues, it doesn't make a
difference. You're not defined as a Ben Eretz
Yisrael. when your kids are still in school
in and that is going to ultimately push
you to always be there. So that was
factor number two that he says has to
be taken into account. Factor number three he
said, it used to be we could determine
something based on where your business is, but
today, that's not so much of a determining
factor because people can have online businesses, they
can live wherever they want, and they can
have all kinds of different ways that they
can make money in different countries even if
they may not live there. So his opinion
is you have to take a number of
things into account and figure out in a
conglomerate of factors whether you're actually considered to
be a Ben Eretz Yisrael. or a based
on all of those different pieces and whether
or not they fit. He does mention that
Rav Shlomo Zalman Auerbach was of the opinion
that if you're in for Shalosh Regalim, then
we consider you to be a Ben Eretz
Yisrael If you're there for less than Shalosh
Regalim, then you're not considered to be a
Ben Eretz Yisrael, Again, that's the opinion of
Rav Shlomo Zalman Auerbach. Rav Asher Weiss has
his own opinion and there's a lot to
think about. If you're going to be one
of those individuals who will be traveling to
you're going to have to figure out number
one, if I'm only visiting do I follow
the opinion of the or the Chacham Tzvi?
Should I be observing two days of or
one day of If I'm going to be
observing two days of which is the major
consensus opinion and what the writes as well,
if you're going to be observing two days
of you then have to ask yourself a
further question: At what point would my status
change? When I buy an apartment in when
I go for Shalosh Regalim in when my
kids are no longer of age that I
have to be back in America, when I
have a business there? All of those questions
are things that have to be considered, but
this is a very important topic to discuss
about this issue. But let me just conclude
with this final thing and that is: If
I'm in and I'm following the opinion of
the Chacham Tzvi, which as we said is
a legitimate opinion, Chacham Tzvi said that you
only keep one day of when you go
to because you should not be different than
any of the people there. And if everyone's
observing one day, you also should observe one
day. If you're following the opinion of the
Chacham Tzvi because that is what your answer
was given to you by whoever you asked,
if that's what you're going to do, the
further question is would I be allowed to
take a flight on Yom Tov Sheini and
come to or not? Technically the answer is
yes, you'd be allowed to do that. However,
the problem is as follows: What do you
do when you land here? What do you
do when you land here back in America?
So, the problem is, when you land let's
say in JFK, JFK is not considered within
the techum of the yishuv of the Jews,
even though it's not far from the Five
Towns community, but it is far, it's outside
of the techum. There are no Jews around
JFK who live there. And therefore, if you
land in JFK on Yom Tov Sheini when
it's still Yom Tov Sheini here, you would
have to stay in the airport for the
duration of until is over. You would not
be allowed to take a taxi to your
house which is then going to bring you
into the Yishuv HaYisraeli, into the Jewish community.
If you come back into the Jewish community,
you're not allowed to do melacha, which means
you're not allowed to be in the car.
So you wouldn't be allowed to leave the
airport, you'd have to stay outside of the
techum until after Shabbos is over and then
you'd be able to then come in and
after is I'm sorry, after is over you'd
be allowed to come in. That's what Rav
Shlomo Zalman Auerbach writes, and that seems to
be what makes a lot of sense based
on the of the Shulchan Aruch. The Shulchan
Aruch says if you have a who's in
he's not allowed to do melacha even You're
not allowed to do melacha when you're in
the context of the Jewish community, but if
you're outside of the yishuv, if you're bamidbar,
if let's say you're in a hospital that's
somewhere way out away from the Jewish community
and you are legitimately a then you'd be
allowed to observe one day of and you
wouldn't have to worry about.